you uh
you talked about losing your mom yeah
uh do you
do you miss her
yeah i mean i still connected her
through music she was a
she was a young prodigy
piano
player in vienna and uh she survived the
concentration camp and then died in a
car accident
here in the us
what music makes you think of her is
there uh
is their song
well she you know she was in vienna so
she's she
had the whole viennese
music thing going
um which is this you know incredible
school of uh
absolute skill and romance bundled
together and uh wonderful on the piano
especially i learned to play the
some of the beethoven sonatas for her
and i played them in this exaggerated
drippy way i remember when i was a kid
and uh exaggerating meaning uh too full
of emotion yeah like just like
it's just it's not the only way to play
beethoven i mean i i didn't know there's
anything that's a reasonable question i
mean the fashion these days is to be
slightly apollonian with even with
beethoven but
one imagines that
actual beethoven playing might have been
different i don't know i um
i've i've gotten to play a few
instruments he played and tried to see
if i could feel anything about how it
might have been for him i don't know
really i was always against the clinical
precision of classical music
i thought
a great piano player should be um
like um
in in pain like
you know like emote emotion emotionally
like truly feel the music and and make
it messy sort of sure
maybe play classical music the way i
don't know blues
pianist plays blues
like
it seems like they actually got happier
and i'm not sure if beethoven got
happier i think it's a different i think
it's a different kind of concept of the
place of music
i think the
the blues the whole african-american
tradition was initially surviving awful
awful circumstances so you could say you
know there was some of that in the
concentration camps and all that too
um and
it's it's not that beethoven's
circumstances were brilliant but he kind
of also
i don't know this is hard like i mean it
would seem to be his misery was somewhat
self-imposed maybe through i don't i
don't know it's kind of interesting like
um i've known some people who loathed
beethoven like the composer uh late
composer pauline oliveros wonderful
modernist composer i played in a in her
band for a while and she was like oh
beethoven like that's the worst music
ever it's like all ego it completely
it turns um it turns information and i
mean it turns emotion into your enemy
and it's uh it's ultimately um all about
your own self-importance which is all
which has to be at the expense of others
could what else what else could it be
and uh blah blah blah so she had i
shouldn't say i don't mean to be
dismissed but i'm just saying like her
position on beethoven was very negative
and very unimpressed which is really
interesting for the man or the music um
i think uh i don't know i mean she's not
here to speak for herself so it's a
little hard for me to answer that
question i'm um but it was interesting
because i'd always thought of being home
i was like oh you know this is like you
know it is like really the the the dude
you know and she's like yeah you know
beethoven schmidt oven you know it's
like not really happening yeah i still
even though it's cliche i like playing
uh personally just for myself muma
sonata i mean i just
um moonlight's amazing you know um
i
you know you're talking about comparing
the blues and that sensibility from
europe it's so diff so different in so
many ways i one of the musicians i play
with is uh john batiste who has the band
on on colbert show and uh he'll he'll
sit there playing jazz and suddenly go
into moonlight he loves moonlight and
what's kind of interesting is
he's found a way to do beethoven and he
by the way he can really do beethoven
like he uh he went through juilliard and
one time you know
one time he's at my house he's saying
hey do you have the book of beethoven's
thoughts to say yeah i want to find one
i haven't played any sight read through
the whole damn thing perfectly and i'm
like oh god i just get out of here i
don't i can't even deal with this but
anyway
yeah but anyway the thing is he he has
this way
of with the same persona and the same
philosophy moving from the blues into
beethoven that's really really
fascinating to me it's like um
i don't want to say he plays it as if it
were jazz but he kind of does
it's kind of really and he talks he'll
well he was sight reading he talks like
beethoven's talking to him like he's
like oh yeah here's he's doing this he's
i can't do john but you know it's like
it's really it's really interesting like
it's very different like for me
i was introduced to beethoven as like
almost like this god-like figure figure
and i presume pauline was too that was
really kind of oppressive and hard to
deal with and for him it's just like
it's a conversation
he's playing uh james p johnson or
something it's like another musician who
did something and they're talking and
it's it's very cool to be around it's
very uh
kind of uh
freeing to see someone have that that
abil that that relationship i would love
to hear him play ben horn that sounds
that sounds amazing he's great
you